a man who's who's celebrating 20 years
of pft
wow on the 1st of november
uh and he's got a book coming out as
well that you can pre-order right now on
amazon here to talk about all of that uh
the author of playmakers how the nfl
really works and doesn't you can
pre-order it right now on amazon it's
coming out next march i think just in
time for the new league year but the
current league year is about to begin
let's talk about it with mike florio of
pro football talk how are you mike doing
great rich uh great to be with you as
always think right back at you i like
the title of that book uh on espn's
anniversary that's right playmakers yep
that'll get the attention copyright laws
that'll get the attention um and so okay
we'll we'll talk about the book in a
second what's on your what's on your
mind uh prior to this league year
starting like what do you think is the
the story of this year that we're about
to embark two days from now on a
football field in tampa well i'll press
pause for now on the reality that a dark
cloud hovers over the nfl again this
year with lightning bolts that will
periodically knock guys out of games
after they test positive for covet like
zach martin most likely missing thursday
night's opener i'll focus on the bucks
first time in 40 years the super bowl
champion has returned all of its
starters they had eight key free agents
they resigned all of them they addressed
their third down running back
deficiencies by adding geo bernard i
think they are in
prime position to do what hasn't been
done
since the 0304 patriots with tom brady
in new england and that's get back there
climb the mountain again
and win it again and i know that
look a lot of things have to fall
any team's way whoever wins the super
bowl many things fall their way but tom
brady has shown over the years he's got
a knack for making things fall his way
and at least getting to the conference
championship game and then getting to
the super bowl and
then getting seven rings and counting so
this feels like really for the first
time since the 2014 seahawks after they
blew out the broncos and i think we all
thought well they're just going to win
another one this feels like the best
chance since then in seven years for a
team
to do it again and to make it two in a
row and of course then the prevailing
story next year would be can they become
the first team ever to go three in a row
right and then what happens to the 12 in
green bay i mean that's another thing to
keep an eye on throughout the entire
year
is to is is how green bay is positioned
to potentially stop
uh
what you just mentioned from happening
right would would you agree that they
are the team best equipped
to prevent it um in the nfc or you're
looking at somebody else well mike the
packers are in the conversation rich
think how different the narrative would
have been about the buccaneers after
last season if the three
balls that tom brady threw up for grabs
in the second half as that lead
frittered away
and the packers had a chance to win that
game the packers win that game and brady
has three interceptions in a meltdown my
god the things that we would have been
saying about brady being done about the
buccaneers having no chance to put it
all together again etc etc so the
packers definitely have the
the talent
starting with number 12 to have another
season in the vicinity of 13 and 3. they
won't go 13-3 because there's another
game but the saints are a team that i'm
still keeping an eye on they swept the
bucks last year and they were up seven
third quarter jared cook catches a pass
barrels his way into tampa bay territory
and but for a
a peanut punch style
forced fumble by antoine winfield jr the
saints are going up 10 maybe 14 points
and possibly making it 3-0 against the
bucks last year so they still have to
deal with them they don't deal with them
until halloween
in new orleans but the bucks have to
deal with them twice and maybe a third
time again and uh there's an argument to
be made that with jameis winston if
sean payton can iron out the rough spots
there's a guy who threw for 5100 plus
yards two years ago that the saints
could be
every bit as good as they were last year
and making them a very significant
problem for the bucks how do you see the
nfc west shaking out what do you think
of that mike
well i think injuries are going to have
a lot to do with it i know peter king
has the rams getting to the super bowl
and winning it my concern is and we've
already seen it happen cam akers out for
the year really hurts the running game
matthew stafford's had an injury history
he plays through a lot of injuries but
he's had some injuries he can't play
through when you put
so many eggs in so few baskets with
aaron donald jalen ramsey matthew
stafford star players and you give up so
many draft picks and you put pressure on
yourself to draft right make good
decisions hope that you can build depth
with your remaining draft picks after
you've traded them away for established
players
do you have that depth and when you
don't have the cap space to go out and
sign
good solid
veteran
level backups and you're relying on
young guys to step up i worry about the
rams i think that the 49ers if they can
stay healthy are going to be very good i
don't like the quarterback ambu
ambiguity i'd like him to pick a horse
and stick with it the seahawks under
shane waldron running the offense i
think will be very good like they were
last year the question is can they
sustain it so i i say i'd go
seahawks 49ers rams right now very very
tightly jammed together and all three
may make the playoffs and then there's
the cardinals and i think cardinals if
they don't make the playoffs i think
they'll be one of the teams looking for
a new coach come january why do you say
that
well when you look at the history of the
cardinals
they've they've been around for over a
hundred years they've never had a coach
last longer than six years two guys made
it six years jim hannafin and ken wisen
hunt bruce erins was there five years
and
the this is
the year when the calamari experiment
needs to come to fruition and if it
doesn't happen it's not going to be
anyone's fault but the coach is
responsible for getting the most out of
murray and just some of the things that
were said throughout the off season by
guys like gm steve khan by murray who's
clearly getting frustrated by not
getting to the postseason i think if it
doesn't happen that's when job number
one in arizona becomes finding the right
coach to build the perfect offense
around columbus give me some more hot
seats
well i think i think in minnesota where
mike zimmer
is is setting the stage to be on the hot
seat by saying i think we have a pretty
good team now we just have to go out and
prove it rick spielman the guy who built
the team is probably very appreciative
of that because maybe that means he
doesn't get fired if they fail to make
it to the playoffs but they have a weird
vibe around them
because of the offense the offense feels
like it's falling off a bit now we
didn't see any dalvin cook in the
preseason but if that offense doesn't
doesn't produce at a high level it's
going to be very difficult for them to
get to the postseason and if they fail
to make it the playoffs for two straight
years i think zimmer could be
in significant trouble
you know beyond that it's just gonna go
i mean other than kingsbury and zimmer
you know who out there has i mean would
mike mccarthy be gone in dallas i don't
know if they'd fire him after two years
zach taylor in cincinnati easy pick for
the hot seat if he's got guaranteed
money in his contract for 2022
bengals don't fire they don't people
and pay them they want their coaches to
work and jerry jones is the same way
probably the only thing he has in common
with mike brown he doesn't like to pay
coaches to not work either and that
guaranteed money for either mccarthy or
taylor beyond this year could help save
them but you know we see it every year i
mean there's going to be bad teams
everybody's optimistic now glasses have
full everywhere everybody zero and zero
everybody's got a chance the end of the
day every team that's good that means
there's gonna be a team that's bad and
uh you know we we see it we saw what
seven last year it's amazing the
turnover but
you know either winner you're done and
you don't have many chances and john
gruden should be on the hot seat
in las vegas but he's not because mark
davis isn't going to fire him you know
mike mayok will be gone i think if they
don't make the playoffs but mark davis
is going to keep john gruden
indefinitely into the future mike florio
here on the rich eisen show pro football
talk um starts our day here on nbc
sports on peacock every single day at
pro football talk on twitter what's
going on with tj watt in pittsburgh
what's happening well mike tomlin the
coach of the team said today he's
optimistic they're going to get
something done
excuse me um
they have some weird rules
one is i'm in a coughing fit here one is
no worries here go ahead go ahead no go
ahead go get it get a sip of water we're
professionals here
one is
that they have to get contracts done by
the start of the season or
that's it okay fine well what's gonna
happen with what if they don't get a
contract by the start of the season
they're gonna have to break their rule
because they've allowed him to show up
not practice
not play
and you know just in this weird holding
pattern the other rule that hurts the
steelers here the fact that they don't
give fully guaranteed money beyond the
first year of a contract that's a real
problem with what he wants full
guarantees beyond this year other elite
defensive players have gotten full
guarantees beyond the first year but but
it feels like they're going to get
something worked out right up against
the deadline deadline driven business
look for what to make a little bit more
than 27 million a year in new money on
probably a five-year extension the
question is going to be how much of it
is fully guaranteed at signing i mean i
i i r
again we're not there i'm not there okay
so i'm not there
but sitting out uh it just seems like
another situation where teams are like
we don't do it this way
and it's like well you you you do it
that way for sure
but why don't you make an exception for
this guy because you can always mention
to other people well we did it for tj
watt you're not in that echelon you know
what i mean like it's so simple
for players to get what they want and
for franchises to bend the rule if they
just had the ability to not break on the
front of looking another player in the
face and saying you're not that person
and you know who's doing that right now
tampa
tampa is totally reconfiguring the way
that they go about their business
for brady and they're not worried at all
that the next part like they're not
worried at all that kyle trask is gonna
be coming to ask for something or
anybody else on the team is asking for
something you're not brady you don't you
didn't come here
with six rings and give us a seventh
it's that simple and it green bay put
themselves between a rock and a hard
place with rogers it seems
because they only do it a certain way i
i i kind of just
it's it's i don't understand you're
right you're right
look you have to acknowledge that
certain players merit certain treatment
and the dealers will bend their rules
they did with antonio brown they don't
renegotiate contracts with more than one
year remaining unless it's quarterback
so he had three years left he wasn't
happy with his deal so they took some
money from the next year and moved it
into the current year and then the next
year they took money from the last year
and moved into that year and then the
last year they gave a new contract now
we know it all went to hell after that
but they've got ways
to work around it if they really want to
but yeah for a great player you just do
it it's tj watt and having these rules
that are separate apart from the rules
that are set forth in the labor deal it
sets you up to not be as competitive as
you could be because other teams are
going to do it and it's going to make it
harder for you to keep the players you
really want to keep if you're stubborn
about
when you're going to do contracts and
what the terms are going to be and why
we don't want to put money in escrow for
next year well everybody else does it
except for the packers so you better do
it too yeah i i just don't i don't get
it i i
you know i it just it's mystifying to me
so um but before i i let you go are you
on the bills uh for this year what's
your afc uh thought on that front i i
think there are nine teams in the afc
the bills the patriots raven steelers
browns colts titans chargers chiefs that
are all good enough
to by the time we get to january be in
the playoffs and make some noise in the
playoffs so it's a very difficult top
heavy division
i did go bills bucks
as my super bowl teams this year and you
know what the hell let's throw the folks
in western new york a bone let's say the
bills are going to beat the bucks
because we have seen tom brady lose
three super bowl so it's not like it
would be unprecedented he can get there
he just doesn't have the winning
percentage in the super bowl that he
does in pretty much every other level of
a season so you know josh allen i think
is spectacular the the glimpse we got of
him against the packers in the
pre-season shows me that he's ready to
pick up where he left off and go next
level there's so many people who think
oh that was an aberration last year well
if you think it was an aberration last
year you're not paying attention
last year was the year that josh hall
and it isn't it
amazing that like if a quarterback
finally breaks through in year three we
what took you so long it was only year
three
and he becomes phenomenal and i think
he's going to keep getting better and
better and i think the bills are going
to be a force this year and and i think
they're ready they've got the chiefs
week five sunday night football right
they have to show that they can beat the
chiefs what's that that's the team
they've got they've got to get past and
once they do they're going to be
unstoppable who's the third team and
we're not talking about because there
always is one who what do you got for me
oh
you know i
i i i was the quarter our friend jude
smith shoes to the browns is the browns
and i can't get past that can't you
gotta i think you have to personally you
don't mind me saying it's the helmet
it's everything about you know how do
you
see that same frame on a car
and not consider
that what's beneath the hood is still a
jalopy it's
and i think that benefits them because
you know how it goes every year there
there are the teams that are the
darlings and everyone circles that game
and we're going to prove ourselves as a
measuring stick game for us and it may
be that teams still look at the browns
and say the browns is the browns like
juju said and that's going to help the
browns live up to their high
expectations but i think it would be
great i just think based on the history
of the browns it like it doesn't want to
compute in my brain that they could make
it to the super bowl i i think we got to
re
rewire then i mean i
look what what what what do you have
um
what what do you need i guess to to to
win a championship right you need
uh a defense that can stop people with a
playmaker maybe on every level would be
helpful
you need you need a run game and you
need a passing game that can be dynamic
because not only who's
grabbing the ball
uh and catching the passes but the one
who delivers it can play with such a
neck up ability and calmness and
efficiency
that you can win
that's the question mark i don't know if
anybody is believing that baker mayfield
really is a first overall pick like he's
not flashing like andrew luck he's not
flashing like anybody who's a number one
overall pick where it's all fixed and
ready to go i think we're still can't
get past the fact that john dorsey chose
him first overall but they've got the
reigning coach of the year they've got
chubb they've got garrett they've got
odell coming back with a massive chip on
his shoulder why not them why not you're
right and what what hurts them is 2019
the last time the bar went north for the
browns and they failed to live up to
expectations because they never should
have given the job to freddie kitchens
and baker's mechanics want the pot he
had a regression stephanie got on the
right track second half of last year he
was spectacular he doesn't have his
contract yet he's going to be motivated
by that
if they don't force the ball to obj
that's one of the things that they have
to get past it can't be about we got to
get the ball to obj unless they want to
do bubble screens and reverses
but if he's running down the field in a
pattern with three other guys
baker's gotta have the freedom to throw
the open guy not we gotta get it to
odell beckham a certain number of times
that has to end and hopefully beckham
seeing what the team did without him
last year will end that once and for all
because that that's an attitude that
keeps a team from being as good as it
can be well i guess when you real quick
then when when does baker or lamar get
that deal that josh allen got when does
he what do you what's going on with that
well i think that once josh allen did
his do i i think that the the
quarterbacks who are represented by
agents alan and baker mayfield i think
they
waited and hoped that lamar jackson
would go first since he's not
represented by an agent
now that alan's deal is done my guess is
lamar jackson has said the ravens i'm
fine with the same contract why don't
you give me the same contract and i
don't think the ravens want to so that's
an impediment and they just did mark
andrews last night giving huge money big
money for their tight end right and my
first question is all right when's lamar
gonna get his with baker i
look i've said hey and cautionary tales
jared goff and carson wentz you don't
want to go too early with a franchise
quarterback it's better to go a little
too late than a little too early
but the problem is the moment you know
he's the guy that's when you have to get
it done otherwise you back yourself into
a corner the way the cowboys did with
dak prescott
mike appreciate the time keep looking
for my call um and you know we'll we'll
chat uh obviously way in advance of your
20th uh anniversary on the first of
november but congrats on making it to a
20th nfl season with your with your
creation pro football talk appreciate it
appreciate you rich look forward to
targeting again enjoy the start of the
season pal you got it that's mike florio
of pro football talk
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here